so i was just looking at your insta
stories on a level of one to ten how
excited
are you that this album is out well i'm
going
i'm going crazy right now like i just
like wanna can i
scream do you wanna just turn me down
that's literally what i'm saying to you
i'm just like off my knot right now
that's so exciting um you know there's
so much i want to talk to you about
especially when it comes to this album
but before we get into it
um 2020 has been a very challenging year
for so many people
you yourself have been very open about
your own struggles surrounding mental
health
how are you doing right now bro the
thing about it is right
2020 has been so hard for a lot of
people and
for all of us but i
i've never felt more connected to my fan
base than
than what i do right now yeah you know i
mean i was just like
i wanted to radiate the idea and
resonate the idea that
just because we can't touch each other
don't mean we can't feel each other
and i wanted to release this album
because obviously it's called weird and
even if there wasn't a global pandemic
going on right now
i wanted it to be an album for the
weirdest years of our lives
you know i i just feel so lucky and so
connected to my fan base and
and the people around our culture you
know i mean i just think it's
it's just mental it's just mad i can't
believe that we're here
yeah you know going from you know
the first time that you're putting music
out to now where you are you this
massive following on social media
um when it came to this album did you
want to be more real than ever or is
that just
you all the time well this is i'm
literally just turning me do not disturb
onto my mom
finds it like text me every time i'm on
an interview
like an inkling in a brain that goes you
know what dom's on a really important
interview with canada right now
and i don't turn do not disturb off
because i forget but um as i say i just
think
what i was saying i was just like this
album it's so important man it's like
it's about them
this album is about every kid from every
continent of every size
shape color sexuality and point of view
and the way they've impacted my life
yeah and this album's so emotional
because i finally feel like i belong
somewhere
like and when you when you figure out
that you belong somewhere
it's like you find out you've got lungs
for the first time
and that you can like you go like oh wow
it's not actually not a struggle to just
exist and be who i am and
all i want to do with young blood is
just radiate that idea and that ideology
you know i mean i couldn't like
everything else like
success and it's and all that thing
that's great but that's second for me
and i think that's why this culture's
growing so quickly is because
music can have such an agenda especially
right now
and i don't want to write music for a
motive
i want to write music for a reason yeah
you know what i mean oh yeah you know i
i just love the title of this album too
did you have that from the start going
into this
or you know once you kind of looked at
your collection of music you're like i
need to call this album weird
well i remember it was the weirdest 18
months in the old existence
yeah i nearly lost my mom in a car
accident
then we got really big really quickly
and it was like whoa this is pretty
unfathomable
went around the world twice fell in love
that didn't turn out so great then i was
on tour
sorry i was on tour having the best time
ever
and i still felt not in my stomach
yeah and then we came back to the i just
couldn't figure out why i felt so down
and anxious all the time but always as
as as as every time when i feel like i'm
about to get lost my family slapped me
in the face and just like yo come back
come back here and i think
it was crazy to me because i remember we
played brixton academy
in london and two years before
me my guitar player and the drummer were
in a two-bedroom
apartment tiny but like literally the
size of the shoebox were live wires on
the wall
like a bucket for the damp literally a
proper bucket for the dam and that
we touched on them wires like your brown
bread mate you know and then
we like sold out bricks we would watch
these videos
the foo fighters and radio ed
and kasabian play brixton academy
and then we we play brixton academy and
it's sold out and it's crazy and then
after the show
like everyone's doing what you do after
you play brixton academy so i mean going
absolutely mental my mom says to me
she's like
we're probably checked out that night i
was like why i didn't know why
but i'll explain to you in a minute like
we partied we did what we did after that
um i went home with someone and then i
actually had to leave at 4am because i
just couldn't sleep
um which was hilarious so i went up to
primroseville
which is a real big hilltop in london
yeah
and i've just sat down at like r5
and i just sat there and i just wrote
down i can't sleep at this time i got
jesus
and the whole poem of weird came out and
in that moment i was like i know what
this album's gonna be about
it's gonna be a a coming of age record
that's an album of defiance defiance to
be
something that you're not and an
optimism and
no matter what life throws at us
it'll all be all right in the end as
long as you tell the truth and love as
many people as you can
well telling the truth is definitely
something that you are known for you're
just so unapologetically you is it
have you always been that way or did you
just realize that
god knows really connected to that bro
i was like i was always pretty loud and
i was always pretty like whatever
but i was very insecure in myself
because i think there's a very big
difference a lot
like i felt loved but there's a
difference between
loved and understood
john i mean people can love you for a
caricature
false ideology that isn't really you
you rather they understand you and love
you you know what i mean
and i think it was interesting to me
because
i would have rather not been loved and
rather been understood
but then i found a community and now i'm
both
yeah yeah you know i'm staying and they
are both
and i think like one the one thing i do
want to reflect is that young blood
ain't
me young blood is us
young buddies we young buddies i don't
know
freddie in toronto and charlie
in london and jens in berlin and
lola in sydney you know what i'm saying
youngblood is a place to go
when you want to feel accepted and you
want to feel
real i love that um i do have to talk to
you about
the album cover for this it's an amazing
collection of
you know different variations of you how
did you come up with that idea
i love war all i love andy warhol
and i just wanted it
to look like a movie poster i think yeah
um and i wanted to resemble i want you
look at a picture
like a warhol picture or painting
you see 15 different things
every time you look it that you might
not have seen before
and that's what i wanted in this cover i
wanted people to
get it and look at it like it was like a
piece of art on a wall
and it just resembles that each and
every one of us can be 15 different
people any one time
and it resembles each side of my
personality and what one day awake was
that person one day i wake up was that
person one day awake was a mix of these
people
and it's just dom in the middle it's
been like
which which person is going to take over
me at today
i love that i do have to ask how
challenging was it walking in those
amazing leather boots
oh but it was so hard man i nearly broke
my ankle twice
probably three times actually but it's
cool man i was
well tall this is a vibe
uh definitely a vibe no they are awesome
um you know we're in the middle of this
global pandemic
show's been canceled all over the world
but you've been able to connect with
your fans virtually so how have the
virtual shows been going
that's been crazy i i think my answer
for everything is like mental crazy yeah
blah blah blah
yeah i mean but it's actually true like
it's actual true thing like
people everyone just loving being
together
in any any form or any shape you know i
mean i was just like again
radiant radiating the idea that just
because we're not together don't mean we
can't make noise
yeah what can people expect when they
see one of your shows
a real show you know what i mean i think
right now a lot of live streams can be
like glorified music videos
yeah this proper like warts and all
rock and roll show i was like j i mean
if like if i hit a bum no i it's a bum
no if i
take my t-shirt off i'll take my t-shirt
off if i kiss my guitar player or kiss
my guitar player if like
i don't know if a camera dies a camera
dies you know what i mean it's like
proper i think that's what's great like
so fun about young wood shows it's just
like
chaos like every show's different you
don't know what's gonna happen
you know i mean like we've had crazy
incidents like
breaking the barrier and stage invasions
and you know i mean like having to stop
the show halfway through because so many
people are fainting and stuff like
we have like mad chaos and that's my
favorite thing
because everyone just unleashes because
it's like i can be
myself yeah i mean and it's just sick
and it
even though it's obviously like i don't
know
a weakened down
cordial drink version of that but it's
like it's still
got that energy like and everyone's just
on twitter like moshing with a cat
got like the cat and it's like
yeah that sounds awesome um obviously
the holiday season is right around the
corner i mean it's essentially here
um i want to know you got your red
jumper
i'm here i'm ready for it i've been like
this since november 1st
you literally look like you're a chris i
look like i'm the nightmare before
christmas
like you're in like the grinch awesome
[ __ ] yeah i'm like in a hallmark movie
so sick um
what is some of your favorite christmas
traditions
oh i love christmas man try to see me
christmas today
uh yes i do fives man look at my
christmas tree look
let me see but we got it yesterday wait
oh
well that's a nice one well then it like
i play like i play i like playing piano
at christmas and like singing christmas
songs and that
oh i love it thanks for the tour that's
gorgeous
don't worry like um me and my mate
went to uh went to like this chris we
were carrying this christmas tree for
like a mile yesterday
so it was very funny so we don't get him
delivered here we're starting
to go just get a tree and carry it
yeah why not um are there are there
certain
christmas movies that you watch every
year love actually
great film um nightmare before christmas
elf what's it called that's okay i
like i love brother i love christmas man
i love it and then to be honest like
in england it's usually a lot of
drinking
and a lot of getting together so that's
gonna be weird this year because
obviously
everyone's got a respect hit man like
just be respectful
let's get over it so next christmas then
2021 everyone can have a good old knees
up and kiss each other
love it um uh do you do you get into any
baking
broth every year me and sisters like try
and make a gingerbread house
and i let the side down every time
like they're so good and i'm just like i
don't know
mine kind of looks like a a gingerbread
pile i still want to see what it looks
like though that's good you got to post
a picture of that i'll post a picture of
it
and i'll tag you in it that's amazing
well thanks so much for your time
congratulations
on your album it's so fun talking to you
you have so much energy i love it
thank you so much for having me give my
love to canada canada i love you
you